this was an original spec script that
bad robot acquired and then JJ and his
producers really developed it into
something that could fit into the clover
verse and they sent me that version of
the screenplay and when I read it I
couldn't believe what I was reading I
made every page wet with my sweaty palms
I pitched them my tape which was making
it something that not only was very
intense but also really fun forty feet
underground three years worth of food
and water everyone outside of here is
dead I think what's special about this
movie it's one of those movies where you
really do want to feel like you're down
there in the bunker and so the fact that
I max is such an immersive experience
think you are really gonna feel like
you're down there with the characters
which makes the movie even more exciting
what was a quiet I'm someone who
believes that the size of a movie isn't
just in outdoor wide shots that a movie
can feel huge even in the most confined
spaces and we took a lot of inspiration
from the great sub movies like The Hunt
for Red October and crimson tide and
these are movies that are also in these
confined locations but arted some of the
most intense awesome action movies and
diehard was also a huge inspiration and
this movie has really big visuals
throughout the entire film I think
they'll be able just a lot of fun I mean
it's what we go to movies for us to be
astounded and entertained and I'm actual
help that a lot I knew this day would
come I think to be able to have that
communal experience when something so
intense is happening and everyone's like
are you are you seeing this right now
you know and when there are huge jumps
and you see people around you reacting
or cowering in their seats and I think
this is a movie that you walk out I want
to be talking about and to have that
feeling like oh my god we all just like
experience something together it's
really exciting I think you know for a
movie like this it deals with a lot of
psychological drama there's a lot of
moments that you know I think will feel
very intense and an even more effective
on that kind of a scream this is a real
pot boiler and it's boiling and boiling
and boiling and then erupts in a way
like no other movie and I think will be
particularly special for those that are
going to see in imax yo no I don't want
to give it away but I think there's a
lot of reasons as to why I max is the
place you want to see this movie but
it's kind of hard to talk about without
ruining the whole thing so just trust me
on that one something's coming
you
you